that steve irwin got hit by that
stingray mm-hmm well the crazy
all the animals dude that cheater
stabbed that one dude on that boat that
wasn't that whatever
he was like gotcha you cheating on your
girl it's about kind the guy's like wait
what yeah they're cheating on your girl
he's like cool
got a knife was like uh stem right in
the [ __ ] stomach he's like
wait what yeah it's about goddamn time
you [ __ ] snitch
you gotta stab that thing larry greco
they got his ass and i met him one time
no this isn't it it would turn out to be
fake though no it's not fake
don't ruin this [ __ ] never mind never
mind no he got stabbed
in that part now right in the stomach
it's about goddamn time bro
joey greco dude that guy's a little
[ __ ] yeah dog you remember a blind date
around the show blind date i feel like
you were you ever on there or no
blind date no dude roger lodge yeah
roger marge was a beast dude
yeah he passed away to neither hiv
um he was great show his fans he dated
vicky gonvalsen
did he really yeah wow
breaking news which is crazy he was
great on those blind dates man
what do you mean yeah he didn't have to
go on him that's why i know yeah
it's easy when your friend has to go on
there he is that [ __ ] got stabbed
that's the guy that's real yeah that's
just entertainment for you
you know that's my own girl she makes me
happy man she's stressful right now
i don't make you what are your what are
your plans what exactly do you think
you're responsible for here
because you can't dissociate yourself
from the responsibility
and that's what it looks like it looks
like your personal space
so now you don't care when we get home
i'm gonna finish my afternoon
on the face kinda looks like
oh [ __ ] he's bleeding oh my god bleeding
easy ease him out of here oh my god [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that shit's real bro it's real to me
dude you crazy bro you're supposed to be
working at the prison bro
yeah this is crazy that's a that's a
fake that man is fake bro
that little nerd deserves to be stabbed
bro dude i'll bite that dude with a
sharp ass grill bruh dude how did him or
the homeboy who catch the predator how
did the cat's predator dude never get
[ __ ] up
because i think he had people in such a
tough like those people were not
fighting him they're like i'm getting
the f out what am i going to fight him
and then hook up with the kids
yeah that's insane these people are
insane on this show
[Music]